peppermint this is going to be a delight
crazy to you my john let's talk about
immigration plastic afghanistan a giant
body guns you know big pew pew sticks to
go boom boom
[Music]
we have absolutely nobody to blame but
ourselves
and possibly elmo let me show you what
it's all about i've been stuck here for
nearly a year and a half now
i haven't heard you laugh one time well
that's because you haven't really given
me a reason to show you what it's all
about
burger king's chicken fries little bit
chicken little bit fries all in a box
that looks like i asked my kids to draw
me from memory
i can summon george clooney watch
hello
oh oh
what's wrong with you oh no i'm sorry
george i did it again i'm sorry how hard
is it not to snap your fingers you know
what it turns out it's surprisingly hard
we are back
a small vaccinated masked audience one
of whom and i'm not saying who has a
breakthrough case don't have covert
though relax of smallpox so it's
completely fine
[Music]
this year started with that and against
all better judgments kept going
do you want me to get in the car and
sing
what are you supposed to do without the
internet go outside that's where snakes
lived here idiots
so what else you're supposed to do read
a book that's where snakes sleep you're
idiots ladies and gentlemen
the bidding starts now
i've only had this show for eight years
and even i can barely stand the sight of
me
it's 1pm everyone it's daily parachuting
teddy bear time
[Applause]
balloons are always fun aren't they
their lips are oh oh
oh
that's our show
thanks so much for watching we'll see
you next week good
which way
i'm gonna go this way
it's over here
you